vous entends tu es à ces divins après ça
tout le reste les mondanités les
cocktails les robes du soir les général
et puis l'été la côte d'azur saint
tropez et pita les rats y en a
ras-le-bol ras-le-bol cette année jean
et moi on n'en pouvait plus
on a fui jusqu en auvergne au fin fond
du cantal une ferme au bout d'un village
d'une saleté d'une bosse dément
les femmes en noir sans art édenté porte
encore des seaux d'eau le visage creusé
ravagé sillonné comme la terre génitrice
convient de labourer les vieux paysan
immobile sur leur banc de pierre moussu
ne prononçant pas un mot pendant des
journées entières lançant seulement dans
un autre le ged rue de leur salive comme
on jette sa semence et est d'un
pathétique d'une authenticité souvent
jean et moi nous nous regardions mais
c'est pas possible ça existe encore tous
mais c'est merveilleux faut en profiter
très vite c'est merveilleux merveilleux
et puis un soir ce soir là je ne suis
pas prête d'oublier
jean est tombé dans le tas de fumier par
le chemin conduisant à la ferme
je l'attendais j'étais à table comme une
chatte affamés je la paie du lait bourru
en écoutant la mélopée nostalgiques des
moutons revenant du pâturage lorsque
jean est entré cette ode j'ai dit ah je
t'en supplie ne fait pas un pas de plus
je ne supporterais pas c'était trop trop
d'un seul coup je suis levé mon coeur
battait violemment petit à petit je me
suis approché de gens je les ai eu mes
longs je crois bien que j'ai pleuré j'ai
dit à jean tu te rends compte bien seule
envie jour nouvelle entente est encore
l'essence à poussière la ville l'horreur
et maintenant dix ans mais c'est ça la
vérité jean mon chéri nous tenons la
vérité
je défaille est il m'a serré très fort
contre lui
il a posé sa main puis censure- macro
hilali vient d'une voix sourde et
animale il m'a entraîné dehors je suis
laissée happer par les clameurs indécent
de cette chaude nuit d'été avec mes
sabots ma longue robe paysanne en coton
bleu délavé je trébuche être la boue ils
purent 1 c'était bon nous avons traversé
l'écurie respirait ses senteurs il m'a
semblé qu'il était ivre
nous avons hâte à la grange dont il a
ouvert la porte il m'a poussé dans le
foin de tout côté dehors dedans ce
n'était comme violement gémissements
allaitement devait en rut
comme nous sommes relevés jean et moi
après deux ou trois saillie l'apa elle
tout mêlé à mes cheveux défaits et à nos
trois ans intime
j'avais acquis une certitude à partir de
cet instant
plus rien ne sera comme un désormais je
ne pourrai plus faire l'amour